this is cereth registered nurse orient
home and in this video i'm going to
demonstrate how to assess the chest and
if you would like to watch a complete
nursing head-to-toe assessment you can
access this card up here in the corner
or in the youtube description below now
to do this skill what you'll need to do
is you'll need to perform hand hygiene
provide privacy to the patient and tell
them what you will be doing and you'll
need to grab your stethoscope so let's
get started we're going to inspect the
chest we're looking for any
abnormalities like lesions or any wounds
anything like that
we're also inspecting the patient's
effort of breathing is it really labored
are they using those accessory muscles
to breathe also we're looking at that
anterior posterior diameter so turn to
the side like that and you're looking
for that barrel chest and can will be
increased in patients with like COPD
they will have what's called the barrel
chest and now what we're going to do is
we're going to listen to heart sounds
and then we're going to listen to lung
sounds so first let's auscultate heart
sounds and we're going to do this in
five locations and they're based on
where the valves are located and I like
to remember the mnemonic all patients
effectively take medicine and the first
letter of each word represents the valve
except for effectively so a would be a
or tick p and patients would be pulmonic
effectively would be herbs point and
this is just the halfway point between
the base of the heart and the apex of
the heart and there's no valve location
there and then t is for tricuspid and
then n is for medicine so again using
the diaphragm we're going to listen at
the right of the sternal border at the
second intercostal space and that's
going to be the aortic valve so to find
that second intercostal space find the
sternal notch go down to the angle of
Luis and then just go a little bit to
the right and you're in the second
intercostal space and this will be the
aortic and we're just listening lub-dub
lub-dub s1 s2 and s2 the dub is going to
be louder in this location then we're
going to go a little bit over to where
the pulmonic valve is found that's on
the left of the sternal border at the
second intercostal space so we were just
right across Kandace listening to love
dub lub dub and s2 dub is going to be
louder in this location then we're going
to go a little bit down to the third
intercostal space and this is herb's
point and again and here love dub that
there's no specific valve here then
we're going to go down to the fourth
intercostal space and this is where the
tricuspid valve is and love s1 is going
to be the loudest at this location then
we're going to go to the fifth
intercostal space midclavicular line and
we're going to listen to the mitral
valve and again s1 is going to be loud
us hear dub and there's something
special about this site this is the
point of maximal impulse this is where
you're going to listen for the apical
pulse so we're gonna set here and we're
gonna counter it for one full minute and
a normal apical pulse an adult should be
60 to 100 beats per minute and his
apical pulse was 63 then we're going to
switch over with the Bell of our
stethoscope and we're just going to
repeat in those locations and we're
specifically listening for heart murmur
so that's swishing blowing sound so
that's what we're going to listen to
with that
and I did not hear any now let's listen
to lung sounds now when you're listening
to lung sounds you're listening for
abnormal sounds and here are some
samples of some abnormal sounds that you
may hear crackles wheezes a friction rub
or Strider first we're going to listen
and tearily
and what we're gonna do is we're gonna
listen with the diaphragm over
stethoscope and we're gonna start at the
apex of the lungs and we're gonna always
compare sides and just enter way
downward and assess all the lobes of
that right and left lung so first let's
start up here okay and we don't want you
take good deep breath in and out so here
we go apex okay we're gonna come here
sides then we're going to move down to
the second intercostal space and this is
going to help us assess the right upper
lobe and the left upper lobe so another
deep breath
then we're going to go down to the
fourth intercostal space and we're going
to assess where our right middle lobe is
and our left upper lobe because remember
the right lung has three lobes and the
left lung has two lobes so let's listen
to our left upper lobe a little bit more
then we're gonna go mid-axillary at the
six six intercostal space and we're
gonna listen to the right and left lower
lobe so you just want to turn to the
side right there
okay other side
okay now let's listen post eerily again
using the diaphragm here the stethoscope
you're going to start listening at the
apex and work your way down and one
thing to keep in mind when you're
listening back here you have the scapula
and you don't want to listen over those
because you won't be able to hear the
sound so you're gonna listen in between
where the scapula and the spine are so
down in these regions right here again
we're just going to compare sides and
you can do this part at the end if you
wanted to whenever you turn your patient
over to look at their back side but
we're just going to go ahead and do it
now so we're gonna start and the apex
compared sides then we're going to find
c7 which is that vertebral prominence
it's the big ball right there you can't
miss it and go down to about t3 and
you'll be in between the shoulder blades
and go a little bit in between the
shoulder blades and the spine right in
there and you're gonna assess the right
and left upper lobes
then from t3 to t10 we're just going to
inch around and we're going to listen to
the right and left lower lobes
okay so that is how you assess the chest
and don't forget to watch that video on
a complete head-to-toe nursing
assessment thank you so much for
watching and don't forget to subscribe
to our channel for more videos